e
what
[Music]
we're live hi guys and welcome to
another now playing we're going to play
a game that I love this is like one of
my favorite games of this year it's
stardew Valley but they just released it
on Console so we're going to play on PS4
today uh I'm starting a brand new farm
so that you guys can join this journey
with me this farming Journey um I am on
the 5th of spring and I've sold a few
things just
mostly um i' I've been focusing on
fishing and a little bit of farming and
um I'll show you guys what I'm working
with here but something important to
know the difference on this uh this
version of stardy Valley is you can
actually focus and have different types
of farms you don't have to have just
like a standard Farm now there's five
different farms and there's ones that
focus on mining fishing and there's even
one for like monsters that come in the
night which sounds a little bit more
minecrafty um I asked some people on
Twitter and it looks like a lot of
people were interested in both uh both
the monsters and the fishing but um I
Heard more for fishing so I have a fish
farm so let's talk about that and let's
let's show you guys what I'm working
with so if you guys have never played
that was a really loud Crown if you guys
never played stardew Valley um I'll give
you a bit of an overview um but it is
basically like Harvest Moon It's a
farming Sim but it has a lot more life
to the town and a lot of other
extracurriculars you can do besides
farming so this is me um I went with
pink hair and pink tails uh for some
reason and because I went with the
nautical theme um look at my windows
they're like all everything's kind of
got this seaf fairing vibe to it there's
a little boat on the table and the rug
is different it's like nautical themed
which is pretty rad this is my farm um
I've already started on some parsnips um
some
potatoes and some beans so that's what I
got going for me right now um the first
thing you do when you want to wake up in
stard do Valley no matter what version
you're playing is you want to water your
plants so that's what we're going to do
first I do have an eye on chat
um and if you guys have questions about
the game uh some people were really
curious about controls and handling we
can talk about that um I played it on PC
for a really long time and loved it this
is the PS4 version so I'm playing on a
controller but when I played on PC I
used a game pad so there's absolutely
zero difference to me personally and um
I think it controls just fine however
people who are used to PC controls will
probably not like this it's um a bit
Fini here and I'll show you some of that
stuff right now like for example
probably noticed it's sometimes it's
hard to water sometimes I water in the
wrong spot that's because it still uses
a mouse for the controls which is weird
when you're on a Gamepad right so um
I'll show you guys there we go so my
right stick is the mouse and if I want
to control like see this I want to see
my journal right so I'll click over
there that was my right joystick now my
left joystick is the
mouse why I don't know I don't know um
that's a weird
decision um there's nothing there's
nothing gamebreaking about about it it
it's still just the best game it's still
like super fun and and lovely to play
it's just a bit you know just a little
bit different especially if you've never
played the game before or you've only
played the game on PC uh without a
Gamepad you might find it a little like
hard to adjust but I really didn't feel
any
different
um yeah I do like the game pad on PC um
I think this is a great game to get like
for like an ex um like a Christmas sale
or something yeah like someone was
mentioning getting that cuz it's like
this is such a good game to spend long
hours on it takes a really long time to
set up your farm like I'm on day five
and like look how crappy my farm looks
um let's
see if anyone has any questions uh
someone let's see bman 707 should I buy
this on PS4 um I would say if that's
your if that's your console of choice I
still think this is like one of my
favorite games of 2016 like it's it's
very good um and I've never liked
farming Sims before so I don't think
it's strictly for people who love
farming simulators um I never got into I
was not into harest Moon and I never got
into like anything else it's just this
one in particular is quite lovely um
some farming or I'm fishing right now
fishing is
a really kind of Zen experience it's
super easy a lot of uh well it's
actually not the right it's simple
simple is a better word it's not easy
because you can lose fish you can um but
it's simple it's a very simple mechanic
it's a one button push doing it right
now I'm going to try to get that
treasure got it and then you kind of
have to hold down
X to raise that bar keep your fish in it
and um Let It Go if your bar gets too
high um this is my this is the
difference of the regular Farm in case
you did play stard Valley before and
this new version which is the fishing
style look it's like everything's
islands and I have all these Bridges to
get from area to area none of this stuff
is cleaned up yeah I haven't had
time um and like I said it's only
uh it's only like day five day six yeah
day six you can see in the upper right
hand corner
um Saturday the sixth oh man my
inventory is full
already I'll actually throw away is
trash cuz I oh man and this sap cuz I
want that wood um I'll show you why I
need wood right now because I am
building a
bridge in near the ocean there's like a
small place where you can buy a bridge
and then get all this money and that's
kind of what I'm working at and it's 300
wood and I only have 224 so that's my
focus right
now um I also have some cool stuff I
could do in town because I have these
geodes and I can open those
up um and then I'd like to donate some
stuff to the museum like that fossil and
I thought there was something else I
could donate but I don't see it that's
it that's
it so um I'll plant these seeds while
I'm at it I have really limited
inventory space which is a huge pain in
the Buns
um so goes it when you start a new
Farm is this game easy for beginners of
Sims like this yes it's uh really
streamlined uh who said that uh yeah it
was another uh bman um this game is like
really easy to get into it really tells
you everything and there's a lot of
cutcenes to help you along the way um is
this in 4k on the pro like it
matters check out how Vivid in detail LS
is no it's not um this is a pretty
simple game but it is really beautiful I
think actually the art style is gorgeous
and uh in case you didn't know this was
made by one dude just one hardworking
Dev
um how do you grow plants that need the
pole um anavan asked that uh I those are
just bean plants they just come like
that you don't do anything
special uh L is kind of the guy who
helped me in this town he's telling me
that uh the community center is a [__]
hole it is
uh but I'm going to fix it up how large
is the world Caribbean Sky asked um man
it's pretty big actually why don't I
show you the map as soon as I'm done
talking to LS
um so I will I will show you that oh it
does help me to see your questions if
you do at Gamespot or do question before
your question just so I can help pick it
out with all the
comments um let me see where else are we
at Q do you set which Farm you want at
the beginning yep goob you set the farm
you want at the
beginning um so there's five different
choices and I chose the fishing one it's
really pretty I like kind of did it for
Aesthetics but
anyway um can you play on an iOS not yet
um the new updates added multi farms and
M uh well I was able to get married
before Bob Jones because I got married
on PC in my previous build um but now
you can get divorced so it's more
realistic than ever it's really dark
actually I mean not that I care
but just get divorced in video game I
feel like that's what life is
for
[Music]
um yes beta land that is how you write
the question that will help
me um this game is
garbage not everyone thinks that is one
of my favorite games this year suck
it I think um I think there's beautiful
games that are not what you expect them
to be I think this game is awesome and
it doesn't
need all the bells and whistles of a hot
AAA game it's got everything I need it's
got sick farming it's got really good
characters it's got beautiful design
fantastic music it's got lots and lots
of stuff for me to accomplish it's
everything I like in a game so it's not
for everyone but it's for me uh yes I am
having fun um how's it playing on
Console compared to
how's it on Console compared to PC it's
really similar um if you like it on PC I
think you're going to like it on
console and it's the same story just a
few extra upgrades like we were
mentioning right like choosing what kind
of farm you want specifically although
if it's your first play through I would
really recommend just the generic one
there's no reason to add you know extras
if you just want to learn how to play
um yeah I see that you see that little
alien this game's littered with secrets
there's seos everywhere in this game um
the game crashes when you sleep on day
four I have not seen any crashes I've
seen a few bugs and I will I can tell
you a few of the issues that I've had um
full of rats sometimes the music just
stops out of nowhere sometimes
um sometimes the inventory bugs out when
I open it and I have to close it and
reopen it again nothing like I said
nothing gamebreaking nothing that
nothing that stops my interest it's like
small things really small things to me
personally but you know to each their
own um but yeah it's kind of like
overall I still still think it's really
neat so yeah this is what it's teaching
you is that this community center is
more than what it seems and
um there's
some sneaky
aliens and weird stuff going on there's
Secrets all over the
place um oh I think I should be able to
get into the mines too which I'd love to
show you guys but first let's just show
you like some of the stuff I'm working
with here you'll see that
there's this kind of broken down
area and there's like that bundle over
there so let's go over there and check
that out there's a little alien in there
scope me
out um I can't understand him so I'll
have to do a little bit more research to
understand what he
wants but I think I know I think I know
what he
wants
so um what should I do now I need to buy
some
stuff could probably buy some stuff
appears oh I want to open these geod let
me do that first you can so easily get
distracted there's like a lot of cool
stuff you can do and I'm meeting all the
people of this town a lot of people
don't like them my arms are really sore
but that's a sign of progress for a guy
like me it's a sign of progress for
everyone I must have done a thousand
push-ups yesterday oh Alex you dream
boat
um
the the mix of people is really
refreshing but some of them are quite
generic characters not all of them are
deep you know some of them are just like
well that guy's a jock you know and some
of them are really fascinating so just
depends on you know your style and what
you like and if you do like someone you
can date them um let's see I think this
game is perfect for the steam controller
have you tried that yes that's um I I
actually have tested it it's kind of
cool because it has that Mouse ability
right with the um with the pad how the
pad works on it
so I would uh I would recommend it with
a steam controller and I would recommend
it uh with a gam pad on PC as well even
though that's not the typical way people
play it but that's how I enjoyed
it I think honestly I just prefer
sitting down with a
controller um for almost every game
besides a shooter in which I think
keyboard and mouse is just optimal for
accuracy um will you be my girlfriend
please
uh
why give me a reason give me a good
reason come on super hemr you got to do
better than that how does it play with a
controller compared to mouse and
keyboard most people like mouse and
keyboard better I like controller that's
just how I feel about it that's like my
end all be all with it better on a Vita
oh man I think it's going to be really
good on the switch by the way cuz you
can take it with you is it procedural in
terms of map layout um is everyone's
unique
uh ads uh you are correct it is
procedural um every every um Farm will
be unique to a degree right like you'll
always have your Farmhouse you'll always
have um a decent plot of land you'll
always have water um but they mix it up
man and it and it leads for some
interesting stuff uh what happened to me
um on one of my builds I had a giant
boulder in the middle of my damn farm
and I couldn't get rid of it because you
need to upgrade all your tools before
you can do it it's a huge pain in the
butt actually um all the animals um um
like all the monsters and the mines are
all procedural as well so you never know
what you're going to get every time you
go down it's different which is awesome
all right so this guy is just basically
saying he wants stuff um what are their
questions I was looking for questions in
there uh randomized worlds preset uh
they are preset worlds
um they are you will always see the same
houses in the same places the only thing
that can change is like the layout of
your farm and the monsters in the mines
things like that like um where their
secrets in the world can like change
slightly um let's see if I can donate to
the museum uh and I will also continue
to look I am Global in CS that's very
alluring I must tell
you like what though
like Source go I'm really more of a
source player um so I've made my first
donation to the
museum and because I've done that let's
check out our
Journal uh I got 250 gold for donating
to museum which is rad because I could
use that hot money um also every time I
find a book in the world it it takes it
to the museum and I can learn more about
the world so things like um animals like
to be pet every day and they need to be
dry and they like to um be warm so if
you do that you're going to get higher
products like you know like better milk
and stuff um you can use fertilizer to
improve quality fruit trees
grow um during their season crops die as
soon as the season ends unless they grow
in multiple Seasons only like stuff like
corn
um this is the last one uh
foraging go out into the world and
forage so um now that I've done that I'm
going to go to the blacksmith and I'm
going to harvest these I don't think
that's actually the right word I'm going
to break open these geodes I guess
technically you can Harvest all sorts of
stuff it's kind of like just a new term
for like making
money o that looks cool what's that
Sandstone copper
ore and I forget what that's called
jagu white it's definitely not how you
pronounce it um my favorite
pastime uh definitely mines I love love
the mines and I can't wait I will show
you guys the mines I just I just like am
super into it and when I played this
before I was 100% addicted to the mines
um in my other save on my PC save I am
into like year 4 and I have like
so much stuff it's
ridiculous I'm like I'm weirdly into it
it's a very fun game and I like going
into the mines um there's like I think
120 levels in the standard mines but
there's
uh there's more mines if you keep
searching you can unlock new areas like
the desert I this place just keeps
going
um do I support the community center or
the evil jerks that run JoJo Mart I had
to play it correctly I I supported the
community center however I do know
someone who uh got a job at JoJo Mart or
whatever like oh joined the JoJo Mart
and apparently like it really harms your
relationships with the people of the
town like they hate your butt
um you're the best in frun escape this
also very alluring I like how much I'm
learning about you guys can you have a
pet you can not only can you have pets
but you can have lots of animals in your
farm so let's um
let's go check that out there's so much
more we can be doing here that I'm not
showing you I've been well I mean that's
the thing right like there's just like
way more than I'd love to show you guys
um didn't you say going into the minds
pulls diminishing results it does in the
beginning but I kind of got addicted to
it now it's like all I do um just
because I like I like hunting and I like
killing monsters so like that's just
something I enjoy this is Demitrius he's
is like a
scientist um and then this is mie and
what I
want um want to construct a Farm
building but I it costs a lot of money
to do this so a coupe um a coupe to hold
chickens and Ducks is 4,000 gold 300
wood and 100 Stone I think I almost have
the wooden Stone but I'm way off with
the money I only have $1,000 and I need
um I need to buy seeds so uh that's a
long way off and then the barn that's
where you get your cows and your Ducks
uh and then eventually uh if you guys
are interested in even like more animals
you can get a horse and you need a
stable um which is really rad because um
even though it's 10,000 and it's 100
hardwood which is actually really hard
to find that kind of wood um the horse
is included which is pretty rad um I'm
going to give this lady a flower cuz I
like
her um it also helps my heart meter oh
let me go back to that sorry I got
distracted I can get distracted super
easy in this game so um I'll show you a
few things here's the map so here's the
town that's me and I'm in the carpenter
shop uh this is my farm I've called it
the beer baren Farm because I plan on
making a lot of beer uh eventually
that's when you harvest uh hops I can
grow hops and then you put them in
barrels and make beer out of them and
it's really fun it's lucrative and you
can make a lot of money doing it so I'm
like 100% going for a beer SL fish run
I'm just going to fish all day and um
make a lot of beer um secret
woods and there's like a Wizard's Tower
in there that guy's pretty rad what's
this it's a desert so you can go there
later um I love this [__] like there's
so many Secrets um up here there's some
train tracks and um a building that is I
don't know if it was like fully built
out in the last game maybe they'll do
more with it but it was basically like
um like a wreck Center where you could
like go swimming and stuff um here's the
mines uh so I'll take a gander over
there there's the
jojamart um some houses there's the
blacksmith I was just there remember and
here's the fish shop with the ocean
where I can uh do some hot fishing and
like you can see my farm in this build
has water going through it and all my
land is on Islands which is kind of cool
anyway um what I was also trying to show
you was that there's heart meters for
everyone in
town
and every time I give someone a gift I
can help increase the heart meter I do
not have any hearts with anyone everyone
hates me or doesn't trust me yet because
it takes time to build up trust and it's
only been a couple days don't worry you
guys I'll get
there um what am I doing questions how
are you enjoying the console edition I
love it I love this game um I was
obsessed with the PC version so this is
just another really good reason to use
it um it's not for everyone I love this
game very very very
happy um there's an adventurer he's got
one
eye can you have an assistant to help
with your farm a Aviator 144 asks that's
a great question um if you get married
your spouse will help you they will help
you do little things um I got married
last game and he gave me coffee every
morning that like helped Spruce me up
and he would water my plants every once
in a while however most the time by the
time I had a husband or whatever I
already had sprinklers to water my
garden so it's like who cares um for all
the hard work you have to do you're
going to have to do it on your own and
upgrade on your own just pain in the
Buns it's dangerous to go
alone uh can you have a pet I I did
answer that sorry uh but you also can
have a dog or a cat um that accompanies
you you got to pet him and he'll help
you out doesn't really do very much uh
can you visit other people's homes uh
Centro asks yes not only can you do
that um hey
Marlin um not
only can you visit people's homes but if
you raise your friendship meter with
them you can go in their bedrooms and
there's like secrets that everyone has
in town some people fight some people
like like the how husbands and uh wives
will fight um I learned that someone was
an alcoholic that was pretty
interesting uh so now we're in the mines
let me show you like why I love the
mines so much so in the mines you can
kind of acquire all these items like
rocks
and gems you'll find diamonds and
secrets that you can donate to the
museum they're all procedural generated
um so they're all different and there's
um some villains down here as well um so
let me get my sword out
here and I'll kill
this ah he hurt me uh you'll see in the
lower right um I have an energy meter
and I have a health meter if either of
those go down to zero I do pass out and
somebody has to revive me like a doctor
in the town revives me and it costs me
money and it cost me items um the only
thing that sucks right now is like I am
like almost completely full my inventory
is already very full so I'm not going to
go too far because like what's the point
cuz I can't actually even put it in my
inventory although I could get rid of
the
Slime I could like get rid of some of
this stuff but most of the stuff's
pretty useful so I'm not not actually
trying to get rid of any of this stuff
right now but we'll go a little further
um there's motivation to go down five
because you get an elevator will take
you down to
the multiples of five so every time I
get to the fifth 10th or 15th and so on
and so forth an elevator door opens and
that is huge motivation this is copper I
need that copper ore so I can upgrade my
tools you'll notice all my tools now are
kind of I mean they're kind of crap uh
what are they even called they're just
called standard pickaxe um but with
copper I can get a copper pickaxe
eventually you can get like a diamond
pickaxe all that stuff super helpful so
I do want to do that uh get my crappy
sword oo I got some coal that's very
helpful see damn it it's already
happened um those are our
carrots um I want to eat those so um
die sword is so
crap um what I'm going to do is I'm
going to put these Stones
down and I'm going to eat these these
carrots when I eat those carrots I will
open up my
inventory and then if I find something
else I like I'll just drop what I think
is the least uh valuable which is
probably the Rocks like I will get more
Rocks Don't you worry about it [__] I
found hardwood that's also really
valuable uh this is the worst slime is
like not that big of a deal and I I can
get more I oh screw you I can get more
rocks rocks are dime a
dozen I could also get more
quartz I'll get more
quartz it's a it's a it's a tricky thing
you guys and
like let's see what my journal entry is
also it's almost 8:00 P.M hot [__] reach
level five I bet you I can reach level
five if I hurry up it's already 8 um my
goal is to reach level five I'm already
at level four I only got to go one more
level so I'm going to just do that that
way I can get down back down to level
five next time I'm here oh man look at
all that copper hot
cop want to upgrade all my
tools this is the
best this is the game you're watching it
this is stardew Valley I love this game
um if you guys uh like this too um no
matter what platform you're on if you
guys like And subscribe this video it
helps us out a ton to make more stuff
that you guys love and stuff that we
like showing you
um just a bunch
of people who love games I can't wait to
tell you guys about them so you guys
have questions you let me know in the
question in the comments I am looking um
I do need upgrades super
badly um what's the strongest axe in the
game aridium you can eventually get
aridium and you know what that might
even be outdated I wonder if there's
even something past iium but as far as I
know aridium is the the bees knees when
it comes
to um all right we made it to four so so
five so see that my elevator light went
on I'm going to investigate what's down
here but I'll take the elevator back up
and what's cool is every time now from
now on I could take the
elevator and that's very
helpful how am I able to get rocks again
I thought I got rid Oh no you're right I
got rid of quartz of course of course uh
the reason I got rid of it is cuz I can
always get more quartz but right now for
everything I need I need rocks man like
I need rocks to like build all the the
coupe the all that stuff needs rocks so
I'm like a little bit more into that um
so now I can easily and then check this
out just go back down to level five so
it's a really nice mechanic um this is
out of order but later on uh you can get
fast travel with this the fastest travel
is um I really like the horse super
convenient goob says I'm trying to lock
down all the games I need quit trying to
make me buy more no this game's awesome
put it on your
list um what's the strongest uh oh wa so
I answered the axe um aridium is the
strongest you have to work your way up
though you're not even going to find
aridium yet um you'll find um Iron then
silver then gold then is there diamond
pickaxe there's diamond and then I think
there's
aridium and they're all worth it you
lose your item for like 3 days which
sucks um it's 11:20 it's super dark
outside this is
a cave we'll go in it there's nothing in
there
um I can't even get that grass cuz my
inventory is so full so let me put some
of this stuff away um it cost 50 wood to
build this but look how much more
inventory space it has so I it's super
worth it I would say this is actually
the first thing you should make because
now I don't have to throw away all this
stuff I have all this stuff
now um I can process that geode in the
morning so what do I want to do now
let's see I have a sunfish a sunfish so
I have an extra Sunfish so I'm going to
eat this Sunfish for energy and I'm
going to do a little bit of I could do
some
fishing um but I could also chop down
some wood and I need wood the most so
I'm going to do
that okay you'll notice that I have Z's
above my head that's because it be
midnight at 2:00 a.m. I pass out
wherever I am and it doesn't matter if
you're like so close to your bed that
you can like jump to it if you are not
in your bed by 2 in the morning tough
butts you pass out and you lose money
and I think it's a percentage of the
money you have so like currently where I
am at like 1,00 you do not want to lose
that like that's not worth it um so this
is going to be my last tree I'm almost
out of energy anyway if you look to the
lower right you'll also notice um my
health meter is gone that's cuz I'm not
in danger uh 1:00 a.m. it's in red it's
telling me
go to sleep stupid
um I didn't find an amethyst so
unfortunately I can't complete that
Quest so I'll go to
sleep all right let's see what other
questions you
have controller support for the PS4 or
for the uh OS yes you can have a Gamepad
on PC um will the future updates be free
so far they've all been
free um are there explosives yes there
are there's huge bombs in it it's really
fun oh awesome um this is really big you
guys um I got a ho proficiency who
doesn't want that and I got scarecrow
and basic
fertilizer um this shows you how much
money you made uh I only made 183 bucks
that's pretty bad you definitely want to
make way more than that um I can way
make way more fishing so I might spend
the day fishing so I can make more money
um who eats a fish uncooked listen man
I'm I'm just a simple Fisher and I need
to I need to increase my
energy
um H it's so
good I need to months to finish all your
games goob Step It Up question can you
kill things you can kill all sorts of
stuff man I killed those slimes oo story
is happening it's Clint that's the guy
who opened up my geodes
that's correct I have been doing that
what do you want if you want to get the
most out of the ore you'll need a
furnace just happens I had an extra set
of blue prints I want you to have
them what a nice dude on this rainy day
I'm going to build some
stuff thanks man I really appreciate
that you are a nice
man I will I will consider you to
upgrade your
tools he walked there in the rain to
tell me that that was a nice guy I've
got some new items in stock a deluxe
fishing pole and some bait you can
attach to it you can make bait to make
fish bite
faster um sources tell me you've been
poking around I got a lot of mail why
don't you pay me a visit visit my
chambers of the west of forest lake in
the stone
tower
um that's the wizard do do you guys want
to visit the wizard so this is a thing
like you I have a million things I can
do do you want me to go fishing do you
want me to see the
wizard uh I can go back to the mines I
mean what do you guys want throw some
stuff in the chat you know I'll do
whatever you guys want to do it's fine
um I got I can slay
10 slimes I can see the wizard or I can
go fishing with my new fishing pole that
I have to
buy I do got yeah it's true
um he's going to kill me I there are
some like not nice people in this game
but I don't think there's any
murderers I could donate that to the
museum uh I'm seeing a lot of
wizard
[Music]
um and enosa I totally get it what
you're saying that it will it might
spoil it but let me tell you right now
there's so many damn secrets in this
game you guys are not even seeing a
scratch of the secrets in this game so
if I go see the wizard which I'm happy
to do because that looks like what
everybody wants to do and you want me to
fight him I'll fight the wizard um I
promise
you uh you are you are not even seeing a
fraction of the secrets in this game
this game's littered with secrets so do
not worry about that um oh you'll notice
it's raining that means I don't have to
water my crops cuz they are like are
going to self waterer which is pretty
cool
um this also gives you a nice idea of my
farm and where it's at it's pretty
crappy right now but I mean I just
started you know give me a break um so
I'll show you on my
map here's where I am and I'm headed off
to the Wizard's Tower so I'm going to go
down there
now
um
does kind of look like Terraria the
combat is so Terraria check this
out that's Terraria combat right
there it's very
simple Unapologetic
combat you should be able to kill most
everything but if they come at you in
troves which sometimes they do they can
kill you so you got to be careful I'm
foraging a little bit and just looking
in the world and finding some stuff
while I'm here might as well
this is the Wizard's
Tower I should probably clear out the
farm ah come in
creepo what do you want from
me rasmodius seeker of the Arcane truth
this mediary between physical and
ethereal master of seven Elementals it's
a lot of
Elementals um Keeper of the Sacred you
get the
point and you Mary the one whose arrival
I've long
foreseen here I'd like to show you
something
behold there he is there's that little
alien guy that I saw
earlier looks like a green Marshmallow
with legs you've seen one before haven't
you yes I
have can you build houses You're darn
totin you can build all sorts of stuff
farm buildings Wells all sorts of stuff
to increase your farm they call them
junimos mysterious Spirits these ones
for some reason they refuse to speak
with
me
I'm not sure why they've moved into the
community center but you have no reason
to fear
them I'm telling about the language that
I saw earlier remember I couldn't I
couldn't see
them you found a golden scroll written
in an unknown language most interesting
give me giveme giveme give
me it's just like Wizards away playing
it for the second time PC in Feb was a
delight and now I feel bad for cutting
down trees
help um you can replant trees uh True
Heart you'll see seeds for like acorns
and stuff and you can replant them um
and also if you just give it time it
could take it takes a lot of time but if
you give it time the trees will come
back um just get trees from somewhere
else and then in the future uh try to
always leave a couple trees around
because they'll drop acorns and such and
such and then more trees will Sprout
around them so they grow on their own uh
it'll be fine there's nothing that is
broken because you've gotten rid of all
the
trees um but you can plant them if you
get some acorns and such and such you
can like drop them on the ground um you
can like till the soil and put the
acorns there tree will grow I promise we
the junimo are happy to Aid you in
return we ask for gifts of the valley if
you are one with the forest then you
will see the true nature of this
scroll you're a wizard
I don't know super Henrik not everyone
can
wizard takes a special
task got to be kind of got to wear weird
hats and
stuff he's going
to stop
assuming the worst of this man he's just
creepy looking he's probably
fine I remember when this happened
before caramel top toad stool does that
even mean cand e a frog I'm a
wizard he's got a a witch
cauldron let the essence of the forest
permeate your body all right getting out
of here guys a
creep oh no I'm drank I drank the
Kool-Aid oh
no oh no I'm on
drugs mushrooms are cave bats cave bats
give you fruit oh oh no I think fruit's
more valuable
wow I'm one with the forest
I am
hi yes my dog approves this game Kevin
loves it I've gained the power of the
mag Forest
magic now I can oh my God that guy just
got me super
high oh
no sometimes you just got to take a risk
but I can't help but feel like I just
got
Cosby it's a bit
creepy well such is life moving
on this guy just got me super
high it's like my drug
dealer so there's a secret past this law
see that but I can't I don't have the
right materials I got to upgrade my
stuff oh there's a creepy lady see how
she's doing I've had a lot of good ex
exchanges
with mysterious people this woman sells
stuff that typically I can't get on my
own um and she overprices the [__] out
of them like look at this kale seeds for
500 bucks get out of here
lady now the rare seed is really good uh
it takes all season to grow one plant
and you have to you have to PL on the
first of the Season or you'll ruin it
it's
$1,000 oh
wow I have not seen this
yet it's a
summer to go grow coffee I haven't done
coffee yet it's awesome to see stuff
that I haven't even seen yet
um I'm going to craft a furnace and I
need to slate all right so cool it's by
the
way
um it is 10:00 a.m. in game it's like
crazy I can still get probably two of
the other things done like we could
probably do mines and do some fishing
that's like how awesome this
is it is really cool to do the rare seed
I do uh
I recommend
it I won't tell you what happens but
it's neat neat is probably the best
word how much wood oh man I'm almost at
three hundo um how many rocks do I have
75 so I need
100 to get a coupe I really have a lot
to go because I need 300 wood but I need
it's the money that's the problem I
would say
so
uh I could cash this geode and go back
to the
mines
um it's not a bad
idea I've already done I've already
showed you guys how to cash geode so I
don't want to do that now we can go to
the Community Center and see what they
want um and then let's go to the mines
and I can do some fishing on the way
home cuz you guys haven't seen that yet
can't believe I got super
high it's not my fault
though you can sell the fish I typically
eat them for the energy CU I need the
energy so
bad um I could probably buy some new
seeds too that's probably smart
hey oh crap it's Louis's
birthday uh Gus wants a largemouth
bass sh
[__]
LS all right so I'm just going to get a
few seeds
nothing I'll just get eight of these and
I will grow some cauliflower cost a lot
of money
but they make a lot of money so you got
to spend money make money you know you
know you know um [__] I need a gift for
LS uh but
um
okay good a flower all
right let me think I can give him that
flower he knows I'm poor I'm just a
farmer I
think this is ls's home cuz he's like
the
mayor what a nice
guy so giving gifts to people on their
birthday increases their heart meter
with you
exponentially um
I have no Hearts still but be aware it
will happen just takes
time um I'm not friends with Louis to
enter his
bedroom one day
Louis he heard me ooh this is Sebastian
this is the guy I married in my first
playthrough um he's a loner he's a
programmer and he's an introvert he
plays a lot of video games uh we played
a board game and I fell in love with him
in the game in a little bit in real life
because he's super cute and um I just
kind of like what a loner is uh when it
rains he comes to the beach and he
thinks about stuff and I just kind of
thought he was really
cool
um I
thought oh I should have done that
earlier I think I I just kind of like
immediately felt a
connection with the fact that like
sometimes he likes being alone and even
when I got married to
him um he would say sometimes I would
like wake up and he would say uh today
I'm going to be alone um and I'd rather
you leave me alone and you didn't do
anything wrong I just want to be alone
and that really hit
me
personally
um you know real Mary because some days
I wake
up uh especially like with this job you
know it's like kind of my job to be out
there and social and talk to people and
get them to be as stoked about games as
I am and some days I wake up you guys
and I I don't want to some days I wake
up and I want
to I want to be
alone and
um that kind of resonated with me and I
think I think you'll find that this game
does have a lot of personal touches to
it there are people who have come back
from war and they have problems with um
PTSD there are people who
are feel like they don't have a good
relationship with their mother or their
father and they're struggling to
identify they're people who feel like
they're not taken seriously with the
career that they've had I mean there's a
lot of people and they have real stories
and I like I I like that and I think
that that is one of the best parts um
what's the benefit of maxing out your
heart meter um that's a great question
goo you get cutcenes and you learn the
inner workings of these people's lives
so that thing I was telling you about
like that guy who
um
uh the guy who's coming back from war
you get a really cool cut scene if
you're friends with him enough but you
need to be oh look at all those
daffodils I'm full I can't do anything
with it but you need to be good enough
friends with him in order to get that so
that's like a reward
for doing the right thing so now that I
in the community center I should be able
to start doing something with these
bundles
yeah so here's a foraging bundle so I
need to actually get another one of
those cave carrots the mushrooms the
Morell mushrooms some
pintar stuff like
that
um oh damn
it construction bundle okay so like 100
Wood another 100 Wood 100 Stone and 100
hardwood
um spring foraging bundle oh there's
some daffodils outside I could probably
actually take care of that right
away and you get bonuses for finishing
each one of those bundles every time you
finish a bundle you get a a real nice
bonus so you definitely want to start
that
process um so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to eat one of these
fish I'll probably eat this
anchovy
yum and I'm going to pick
these
daffodils
and I'm going to give them to the aliens
give me give me give me oh man it's
already 4:30 in the game it's like goes
way too fast I thought I saw defil in
the corner of my eye no I'm
nuts I'm
nuts hi Sandman thanks for coming if you
guys are just joining me I'm playing
stardo Valley on PS4 this just came out
on the
PS4 I love this game and I can't wait to
tell you guys about why so please tell
me any questions you have I'm happy to
answer
them I forget what damn bundle it was
there we
go Boop so it's as simple as that um
once I find a horseradish a leak and a
dandelion I can finish that bundle it
rewards me with stuff like anything from
seeds but when I finish the whole pack
like when I finish that room you get a
huge reward and those rewards are stuff
like uh H fixing up your green house
that's huge one or
um it fixes up an area of the community
center but it also fixes something in
town that I promise you you
want a largemouth bass for
Gus who is
Gus feel like I should know who that
is Gus Gus
Gus oh it's the guy who owns the bar all
right cool I can do that I can take care
of that
too so I'm fairly confident I caught a
largemouth bass a while ago and I put it
in my storage container which is again
why you should totally have a storage
unit right
away
um so let's see let's put some of this
stuff in here I'll sell that clam
there's more clams I got clams for days
um was it a [__] was it a smallmouth
bass or was it a larg mouth bass I
thought it was a large mouth or sorry I
don't even know
delivery Largemouth bath damn it
Gus I don't know if I have a large mouth
bath
dude I think you're out of luck
man
sorry well I can go fishing you can go
fishing see if we can get lucky you
never
know um oh I could uh put those in the
foraging
bundle and I'll till and get rid of
those cauliflower
seeds yeah it's a good
day um I love how Zen this game makes me
feel I there's so much to do but it's
not in the sense where you'll feel
overwhelmed uh not for me anyway I never
felt overwhelmed not once I was just
like always felt like I was calm
and having a good time I really really
like this game I hate it when I don't
when they don't match it bothers
me but it's like what are you going to
do I am going to sell this
[Music]
clam um I already showed you guys the
community center so I will do that on my
own time I'm not going to go back back
to the community center I'm going to
fish for a little bit and see if I can
get a largemouth bass so that I can give
it to Gus that's what I've decided to do
now I'm not entirely
sure where to get a largemouth
bass but it makes me feel
like the ocean would be the best bet so
I'm going to try here for a second but
if I don't have any success I'm going to
the ocean super Henrik I do like Bob
Ross I was like obsessed with watching
Bob Ross on Twitch and I watched him
like before right
like on TV I remember it being on like
NPR I'm like Channel's
young I don't think I ever painted with
him I think I just watched it cuz he was
just like this
chill dude smallmouth bass again where
are the large ones where do I get those
large
bass got a JoJo Cola I can drink that
for energy so I'm just going to go ahead
I've been drinking weird [__] all day so
what's another
one what's the best way to earn money
for the 24 backpack um it's Nez that's a
really good question there's lots of
ways you can do it I have actually found
that um fishing is quite lucrative I can
f i can
typically um get a 100 sorry like a not
not always a thousand but I can get a
lot of money for fishing a day um if
you're not into fishing I would really
suggest getting 300 wood and opening up
the beach uh we can actually do that
tomorrow morning if you want um it costs
300 wood but across um the beach is a
bunch
of uh shells oh [__] it's a tough
fish oh that
gu that guy's giving me a run for my
money no you [__] damn it that
probably was a really really good
fish um yeah you know what let's do that
cuz that's really smart I'll show you
um so I'm just going to um get 300 wood
by getting rid of some of these trees I
don't really need all these trees
here
um also it's almost like nighttime it's
[Applause]
like wood wood wood wood wood I'm
cleaning up my farm while I do this too
it's kind of like symbiotic there's a
lot of symbiotic relationships in this
game I'm not collecting any of that
grass cuz I'm full already I'm always so
full technically I don't need this bass
so I'm just going to eat it in the
beginning of this game I'm kind of gross
just like constantly eating raw fish
like no wonder no one likes me I
wouldn't like
me it's all starting to make sense now I
think about it kind of just this creep
this creep new girl who used to work at
the JoJo company that everyone hates the
JoJo
company and now I'm
here and I eat raw fish in front of
people yeah it's all coming together
now Farm
Life
that's right Gus is the saloon guy the
problem is is finding that largemouth
bass now I have all day tomorrow to do
it um which is the reason I'm focusing
on uh collecting wood right now because
I can do both of those tomorrow tomorrow
I
can uh try to get a largemouth bass for
Gus but I can also now that I have 300
wood I can take care of some stuff and
make some money which I really I really
actually need to make some
money so just going to fish for a little
bit
in my own
backyard what's wrong with little Jojo
Jojo is
the superm mar here and it's kind of
like bad for the environment people hate
it cuz it's like a small town right and
small towns
hate
corporations so they just don't like it
cuz it's a large corporation large mouth
pass damn
it small mouth bath are easy to come by
I'll tell you that right
now
Shad who the hell is
shad what smells where it's fish breath
probably fish fish breath I think maybe
I don't know fish eating a raw fish fish
is just not going to make you any
friends I promise you that well unless
it's sushi now I think about it we're
kind of
inconsistent oh there's a treasure I
kind of want that
treasure all right I'm going to go for
it treasure hype all right so I got
treasure now I got to get this
fish come here give me this fish and
then I got to go to bed cuz it's 1:00
a.m. I'm pushing it another smell mouth
bass damn oo
I got a lost book that goes right to the
library automatically and then I can
learn more about the town by going to
the library so I got to hurry up and go
to bed before 2:
a.m. I didn't make a lot of money again
today but tomorrow I'm going to make a
lot of money I promise I also learned
some new
crafting I guess we can go over crafting
a little bit too I haven't really done
that look how little money I've made
I've made
such small amounts of
money but this game starts slow when it
builds all right hurry up I got stuff to
get done
today all right here we
go I have a
[Music]
male uh yeah this girl made fun of my
Cottage
Robin [__]
make fun of my
Cottage um I should have sold those fish
but I was afraid um that I was going to
run out of time so I didn't do
it anyway what am I doing
today what do I want to get done today
that's the question right I don't need
these these fish so I'm going to sell
them uh I need to water my plants and
then I'm going to get the wood that I've
collected in fact I'll do that now so
don't forget there we
[Music]
go and I'm going to open up the other
area of the beach and I'm going to get a
bunch of seashells and clams and stuff
that you can sell from the beach damn it
there we
go um these are beans they oh I
harvested
nice
uh I got some
potatoes that's
[Music]
nice got to water your plants every day
or they won't
grow oh I know what I need to do I need
to craft I can craft today too these are
the cauliflowers that I purchased so
they've already
sprouted off
F some more
water cool
so
um I'm just putting one of everything
down in case I need it sometimes that
happens uh fiber coal and wood I got it
let's do it so I need one
coal and I need all this
fiber and I'm going to make a
scarecrow crafting is really easy in
this
game and that's great he will keep away
the birds that have been eating my crops
but it gave us a little bit of a problem
didn't it in that now I don't have 300
wood so let's chop down just like one
more tree that should be enough I'm
going to sell those potatoes that's my
selling Box by the way I don't think I
explained that earlier
um so I'm just going to chop down this
tree down you
go sick 300 wood R
cool
so just getting rid of stuff I I know I
don't need right now because I need the
inventory
space I might go
fishing but I don't for seee me going
into the mines
today yeah my version of Zen is that I
still get frustrated but I'm happy
frustrated yeah that's right Robin
shouldn't talk trash she's got a lot of
nerve honestly
I'd love to see her Beginnings this like
literally me starting a new life
lady like gave up the corporate life to
do this and you're
being an a-hole about it it's
unnecessary in my opinion all right cool
so this is what I'm talking about uh so
I'm going to fix this bridge it cost me
300 pieces of wood uh but no money right
and then once I do that this whole area
opens up
and there's coral and other stuff and it
it continues to replenish I guess is
what I should say so um that's free
money every day I can come back here and
get it if I want to um and then I can
also fish and hopefully we'll get a
largemouth bass and if I don't then you
know you don't what are you going to
do can you grow shrooms you can find
them they're forage shrooms are foraged
you can find mushrooms in the forest and
you can eatat
them and I think there's bad fish or Stu
there's bad mushrooms too like mushrooms
you don't want to eat that'll um hurt
you I don't think they make you get
High um as far as I'm aware you cannot
cultivate marijuana or mushrooms or
anything uh
controversial would be kind of cool to
be a weed farmer though it will really
change this game Dynamic a lot just like
hanging out super small town girl
growing a bunch of
weed making a lot of
money it's
like like a Pablo escava
story I've been watching a lot of
Naros it's really
good oh [__] so like my inventory is
full already I really need to grow my
inventory
um from the Mart costs me $22,000 but
it's super worth it cuz look at this
crap yes you can rage through people's
trash but they get mad at you if they
find you doing it and they will deduct
heart points like like points if you if
they catch
you um trying to think of what else I
want to get done today it's almost
noon still pretty early I have not
caught a largemouth bath
hello whatever your name
is I could
probably to try to fish in the lake in
the northern part of town for a
largemouth bass I will let's try
it um let me get rid of some of this
inventory so I'm going to sell the coral
and this
oyster uh I'm trying to keep one of
every um fish cuz it's good but I
already have one of
those all right I'm running out of space
jeez that happens really fast doesn't
it so we can try to go to the northern
part of
town I can also get rid of these if I
give them to the community center so we
could do
that so I can give those to the
community center sell this community
center fish for largemouth
bath you can get distracted so easily in
this game oh my thing's going on what do
you
[Music]
want nice just got 100 gold for like
kind of like leveling up I
guess
so to the community center to give these
aliens some stuff hello who are
[Music]
you
uh that guy's a drug
dealer there's drug dealers already in
this
town and he's like this is my territory
get out of here sell
myth just like take it easy man I'm just
a simple Weed
Farmer what is your top game of 2016
what are you excited about in 2017 ice
wolf
gaming
I think this might be my favorite game
of
2016 it's either this is a toss-up
between
this
um I play a lot of OverWatch and I
really
loved oh there's like a few I really
enjoyed Doom but I don't know if I would
make that my game of the year I really
did like it though like very very very
very
much
um and The Last
Guardian it's just
really really
good so this is about foraging this
entire
thing
construction what the hell am I supposed
to do with this
parsnip dang
it suppose I could eat it yeah this is
about foraging but when I finish this
one there's like ones in here and
they'll be about like growing um
or building like eggs and stuff and like
this one will be fish
and it fixes up the whole Community
Center it's really cool all right
largemouth bass here we
[Music]
go that's a pretty smart idea Maru oh
cool that's for my foraging bundle that
leak sick all right so sorry dude when
you were talking
about uh there's the homeless guy I can
give him my parsnip he likes it when I
give you when you give them food
hi you're
welcome I know you're homeless um I
wonder if he meant up here so like this
is like a nice open area it might have a
largemouth bass so let's give it a
whirl
um man this game is so good for the
price I think personally actually um
it's a lot of content it's filled with
stuff to do you can pour I mean I'm over
aund 100 hours in I would say maybe
even 12 or so cuz like I'm on year four
it takes like so long to get that far
have I
played Banjo
Kazooie
yes it's been a really long
time uh but I have played
ukulele
recently all
right nice freaking call
man all right so I'm going to
Gus um but you know what the good thing
is is I know where he he's going to be
um he's going to be at the tavern so I
can get him later um right now there's
those see those bubbles um those bubbles
mean that the fish be popping so I'm
just going to fish here for a little bit
and try to collect a few more
fish apparently it's filled with
trash freaking
Lake
um I can throw that trash away
oh
sick nice so I'll just throw away this
trash make room for more
fish he probably does want to make some
fish and chips out of it he gives you
recipes you
know he gives you a lot of stuff if
you're nice to him all these people give
you like bonuses if you treat them well
like
um they send you [__] in the mail if
you're friends with them oh man blowing
up oh
egg all right this might be my last cuz
I'm running out of inventory space darn
you I
don't who keeps putting all these CDs in
The
Lakes the town should be thanking you
for cleaning the L the lake yeah I have
uh really rid them of a lot of broken
glasses and CDs oh [__]
[__] damn
it I got too greedy I wanted that
treasure the bounce on the bottom can
really uh wreck you if you're not
careful nice
cool it's pretty successful if I had
more inventory space I would do way more
but I don't so I
can't so I
will do those things that I said I was
going to do let's go to the community
center drop off this hot
leak and then we're going
to go to the bar oh we'll play the bar
mini
game and then it's like we'll see like
that's probably like it cuz it's like I
could play this game all night with you
guys but like this game of the year I
got a lot of stuff to do I'm getting
killed by Game of the Year stuff that
I'm supposed to be taking care
of sick bundle complete give me all that
stuff so now that I've done that this
turns into a flower and I get a reward
and my reward is 30 seeds which is
actually pretty good and then that alien
weirdo guy takes the
package and delivers it somewhere I
don't even know what they're
doing they're kind of
like probably determining our death from
it it's kind of like the
arrival
um and then there's like all these sweet
fish you can get let's see what do you
need sardine I got
that uh so I got got a largemouth bass a
chub a largemouth bass and a carp do you
want any of
those I have a Shad I have a Shad at
home I
think yes so I still have one to give
him in fact I'll even give him the
silver one
nice
carp I got that too
red chub I wonder if there's any room
for a
chub this game
really isn't good if you
have a childish
mind
[Music]
um sick
delivering Largemouth
bath
hello dude you need to like do something
with your
life I'm not impressed with that
guy I bet he has a really low marriage
rate I wonder who like who gets married
more hello I have a largemouth bass for
you when you come complete a delivery it
makes their heart meter higher and you
also get money so it's super worth it I
still have no hearts with any of these
freaking
people but again it's still really early
like it goes up I
promise
um unfortunately it's a little late for
me to donate that thing to the museum so
let's play a
game um let's see these are game like
mini games in the
uh oh
shoot these are like mini games you can
play like a shooter and then there's um
a cart game that I really like to play
but I'll play this one
first you can play these inside I think
it's cool that there's games inside I
know they're not like amazing um I just
think they're fun that he did it at all
honestly that there's games inside game
is it's
fun little peashooter and then there's
like
bonuses oh
god oh no I'm in
trouble okay I'm all right here we go
come get
some it's High Noon oh [__] yeah so
like
not oh God
[Music]
buts I'm really bummed about that I just
wanted that wheel so bad and it wasn't
worth
it all right let's try again cuz I've
been to the other areas of this one so I
can show you at least oh if you win
these games they give them to you and
you can have them in your house it's
really
cool um cuz I've beaten the cart game
before it gets really really really
freaking
hard cool all right so this is the new
[Music]
area come get
some oh no they're coming to get
some all right so I've activated my
power
up uh which was a shotgun and as you can
tell I have three shots instead of one
and it's really nice [__] so it's done
so now I have that
wheel
um which I could probably utilize if I'm
in danger I'm doing okay though oh
God F
off a that guy came out of
nowhere
but it's all right I'm doing okay well
I'm not but I don't really want to win
this anyway it's kind of
boring like I said this isn't like a
game I
play very much I just think it's cool
that he added it like I like that it's
here I enjoy it I enjoy the that I can
do this even if I wouldn't play it very
much so I'm using my bonus just to use
it uh basically makes bullets come out
of my butt it's kind of
nice
um I don't know what that death is I
assume it kills everything on the field
but I honestly couldn't tell you I don't
recognize it
cool there's a little star kind of want
that all right so I just killed
everything what's that guy
saying oh
sick little winner I'm a
wienner oh the game volume is pretty low
sometimes um I'll let Mike know he's
supposed to be in charge of controlling
the game volume for Resident coneval and
he's a lazy son of a [__] oh my
[Laughter]
God all right I'm going to quit this
game I'll just I'll I'll die I really
don't care it's fine cool so I'll quit
and then I'll show you guys the other
game that I
like what's the only other game in
here I said
quit okay cool that's a weird controller
issue X didn't work I use
R2 oh
no this is my favorite game and I don't
have the key yet damn I forgot I took it
for granted you can there's a really
cool cart game and you like ride on a
cart it's it's really neat I like it
anyway I obviously need to get the key I
thought I had
it Jesus Shane what's your freaking
problem what do you want what do you
want from me
you want this you want this fish [__]
you
dick that guy
sucks just a farmer just a simple fish
farmer
God he's everyone on my
case
yeah you'll get hate for getting me to
dab all right I haven't done anything
cool feel like you're supposed to do
something cool before you
dab maybe if I catch a fish I'll catch a
fish and then I'll do
it
oh see them bubbles you always want to
fish where you see them bubs cuz you're
going to get lots more fish and then you
know you got in the fish um because you
see the Sparkles that's like the that's
the game telling you you done good
kid I almost lost it I had to keep it
together all right cool small
Mass here you
go I wish it was for something
cooler takes forever to achieve things
in this game you know um like I would
love to get a chicken Co on this show
but I think that's probably like I want
to say at least 6 hours of
work maybe less I mean I don't know who
am I I already got a th000 bucks I think
if you played your cards right you could
probably get it un less but you know
things in this game aren't meant to
happen quickly they're meant to you're
like meant to just
chill
you know you're just like like meant to
zone out enjoy this game like if you're
playing
it you will naturally want things you
know you're going to want that horse and
you're going to want those sprinklers oh
God do I miss sprinklers but you don't
play it to achieve just to achieve you
play it to experience and a lot of the
best part of the experience is not
having any of this stuff it's earning it
over time like that's where I have the
most fun is getting
there sorry I got distracted reading
chat and I almost lost this
fish
nice you like the way the mic is close
this is just my mic it's just a
mic I just don't like it oh I'm almost
out of energy all right
crap I got to be
careful um I can actually get
exhausted it can happen happens to the
best of
us all right so let's sell these fish I
don't need all these
fish and I'll try to sell this broken CD
but I don't think I don't think he'll
let
me I'll go to bed we'll call
it was a good was a good
game
dude I could sell you on the zena stardy
Valley any day I promise like I just
feel it and look at this look how much
more money I made so um foraging and
fishing netted me 500 bucks and then
some a couple potatoes got me 3300 so I
made
$800 so if you can consistently do that
like if you can always upkeep your
Gardens that you're making like you know
a couple hundred um a harvest and you're
fishing regularly you're going to be
making
you know a decent amount of money
consistently and you will grow so much
like so
much
um there's a hat Mouse you can buy hat
I've been there it's pretty cool again
more secrets there's Secrets all over
this damn place this is my farm so
far thank you guys for joining me on
this rad journey in stardy Valley let me
switch the camera um I'm going to get
off the show now
because it's time
man it's Game of the Year oo game of the
year is here and uh there's a lot to do
and uh I can't sit here playing stardy
Valley even though I want to thank you
guys for joining if you like this kind
of stuff if you like us like hanging out
playing games it really does help if you
uh hit the like button or subscribe and
or um because it kind of lets everyone
else know that we should be doing more
of this stuff um this is the kind of
stuff I like to do so if you like that
it does help us out so I really
appreciate it um if not just watching is
also really helpful how often do I
personally stream I don't stream every
week it just depends on like what I got
going on cuz I also do a lot of post
stuff I'm like um a producer so make all
our live shows um so like I help produce
the lobby which is weekdays uh Tuesdays
at 2 p.m. oh I'm supposed to pimp um a
live stream we have next Monday um we're
doing a 5 hour live stream for Game of
the Year we're counting down literally
so like number five number four number
three number two number one and then you
get we you get to find out what games
spots game of the year is live um it
starts at 10:00 a.m. next Tuesday that's
the 20th um Pacific Standard time and if
you guys want to do that what we're
going to do for each hour is we're going
to like announce what it is we're going
to talk about it we're going to show any
sick videos we made over the year of it
and then we're going to play it so it's
like we're going to do that for every
game number five through number one it's
going to be awesome so I would
definitely do that so if you want to see
a stream again I would definitely pay
attention to next Tuesday at 10:00 a.m.
uh for a game of the year live stream
other than that that's about it you guys
um thank you guys for joining me uh my
name is Mary and this was stardew Valley
one of the best games I played in 2016 I
hope you had a good time I hope you had
fun and I'll see you guys again next
time going to lower my mic
now so you can't hear
me but I'll keep the game music
up
[Music]